okay anyway they went into overtime what
happened in overtime okay we're having
overtime let's see trying to hang oh
okay I go defense first uh whistle blows
I'm able to escape in like 17 seconds
and then immediately after I go on his
back and he gets out in exactly 17
seconds I'm like all right I
thought I had a good start and then uh
he gets on my back right after that and
uh he's able to ride me out for pretty
much the entire round
after that he uh I got back on his back
he escapes him maybe like a minute and
some change uh I think where I went
wrong in the overtime is I should have
went I should have been less adamant
about chasing the submission and more
aware of collecting time if I kind of uh
diverted my attention towards acquiring
you know time on the clock it would have
been you know more in my favor but yeah
uh at the end of my uh overtime round it
would I'm able to lock up every naked
choke over the face but there just
wasn't enough time to fully finish you
know I got a few seconds of squeeze in
there I didn't have enough uh time to
adjust then
good do you think if you're on stairs
you would have finished the choke I yeah
I mean for sure for sure if you're on
gear you're you're changing the biology
of your body right you're adjusting your
DNA for sure if I adjusted my DNA I mean
it's a finish so you're implying you're
a natural athlete oh I'm definitely not
a triathlete yeah
heavy implication
[Laughter]